the last time i addressed this august
ted crowd was in 2019 from the main
stage in vancouver where i was giving my
talk my first ted talk on the case for
having children
and that's where i shared the news i had
just received earlier in the week that
my then two-year-old daughter nuseba was
diagnosed with stage four cancer
and needed a full liver transplant
um
so how have your past three years been
as you can imagine
our last three years have been uh
eventful
however
they have given me some tough
learned
lived experiences and lessons about this
ephemeral thing we call hope
and apparently there's a huge demand
for hope right now in 2022 we're all
dealing with multiple crises a pandemic
has killed 900 000 americans there's a
partial lockdown there's disinformation
there's income inequality the rise of
white supremacy people telling people
like me go back to where you came from
we have to learn new greek letters every
few months and oh yeah there's climate
change but other than that things are
pretty peachy
and with all of that you might be asking
well then why
should we be hopeful
in such hopeless times with jihad
and that is a very valid question
and it's a perfectly fair question
but hope is what allowed me to believe
that my daughter would somehow survive
and she did and so if i may allow me to
share briefly three pieces of advice or
lessons um or things that we can do that
gave me hope
in hopeless times and that i hope can
help you
number one
tie your camel first there's a great
saying
uh in islam many muslims know this that
have faith in god but tie your camel
first
as a dad i felt utterly hopeless with
nusaba's cancer
i'm the dad i'm supposed to fix things
but i couldn't fix cancer
cancer
plays for all the marbles it's a
relentless
brutal
remorseless killing machine it does not
care about your vacation plans it does
not care about your bucket list it does
not care about your netflix queue it
comes
for everything
then
chronovirus awesome
how do i defeat coronavirus a 41 year
old middle aged slightly overweight male
with flat foot
uh it's easy
to feel helpless
out of control adrift
but at the end of the day
try letting go of what you can't control
and just focus on what you can control
the simple stuff
wear a mask
get vaccinated
take care of your daily chores
something that makes you feel that you
have some control some agency in this
world when it came to nuseba that meant
as a dad just to be present you know
building her her lego friends set when
she asked me to build it
watching frozen 39 times then followed
by zootopia 46 times then followed by
moana 56 times getting her the tasty
frozen yogurt from the hospital vending
machine that she loved
do what you can
the best you can
have hope but tie your camel first
and then
be like elsa from frozen and let the
rest go
number two
invest in joy
make the intention
to actively invest in this thing called
joy every day
almost like a workout you have to commit
to it
it has to be a discipline
build and flex that muscle the world
does not need more masochists or martyrs
it does not need more overworked
overstressed burnouts new rule for 2022
you deserve to have moments of joy even
if they are fleeting every day that you
are alive and you have to take those
moments you have to grab them you have
to seize them i love food so i learned
how to cook pakistani food took my mom's
recipes during lockdown my kids love
lego so that means now i love lego i
love drinking chai i make a cup of chai
every day makes me happy no matter how
much stress or pain or misery i was
going through i made sure to invest time
every day to invest in things and people
and experiences that gave me joy and
finally number three
i would recommend humbly
invest in the narrative of hope
because the alternative
is apathy and cynicism
investing in hope is painful
it means opening yourself up to the
possibility of pain
betrayal
and disappointment
it's easier to court cynicism right you
expect nothing so you lose nothing
but it also means you have resigned
yourself to the cheap seats you are a
spectator who yells out boo instead of
being a participant in the ring where
your nose could get bloody but at least
you're pushing the ball forward
it means choosing apathy and nihilism
which is comforting and easy but also
lazy and destructive
during the sabers cancer i used to sit
up every night after my family went to
sleep and i stayed up till like 3 or 4
a.m i couldn't sleep
and instead i imagined like doctor
strange in avengers end game with the
time stone every possible scenario an
outcome just to prepare myself as a
father i had to emotionally prepare for
every outcome so i used to imagine
nuseba dying
i imagined burying her with my own hands
i imagined making the phone call to her
grandparents explaining that she had
died listening to them cry
i imagine living the rest of my life
like a shell of a man but pretending to
put a smile on my face because i had a
son to raise and now a daughter my wife
badass that she is was also pregnant
during uh nusaba's cancer
i had to be prepared
but i also chose to invest in a
narrative in which nuseba lived
and i imagined seeing her alive with a
liver transplant smiling regaining her
hair full of joy and life
i preferred that story
that's the story i invested in
even as we were sitting on the edge of
what seemed like a falling cliff
i decided i would put out the lawn chair
and at least enjoy the scenery
over 500 people mostly strangers chose
to sign up to be donors for nuseba even
people who told me they hated me for my
politics
they were moved by her story sometimes
some people can change
sometimes
some people
can choose
to do and be good
an anonymous donor shawn zaheer decided
to give a piece of his liver to a girl
he never met just so she could live
i'm not pollyanna i'm not a foolish
wide-eyed naive optimist i'm a
pragmatist
fully aware of the many challenges and
horrors we are facing but through my own
personal experience if it is all helpful
i can assure you that walking through
this forest
of horrors
going on this journey wherever it may
lead
if you choose to invest in hope it at
least makes the ride
a bit sweeter and easier
and as the wise ram tells poe in kung fu
panda 2
your story
may not have such a happy beginning
but that does not make you who you are
it is the rest of it
who you choose to be
right now
survival
is victory in this story that we are
living we are alive during a pandemic we
are winning and just for that we should
be grateful and i hope the choices we
make in these challenging times will
inshallah god willing lead to a better
story for all of us and i believe that
begins with choosing to invest in hope
during hopeless
thanks so times
for that wash it was
really wonderful to hear and i think in
fact we might even hear it
in the in the background which is uh
which is i think exciting i'm sorry
that's her it's virtual school i'm doing
the best i can no no no no
the wildlings are right there what's
keeping us from the wildlings is a very
thin wall so let's pray
i mean i i think we talked about this
before we we started that we're we're
all at home right now that's the thing i
think uh we we all know so um you know
that's that's what it is um but
i think before we dive into just talking
more about what you've suggested around
growing hope i'd love to start by
talking a little bit about your book uh
go back to where you came from because i
think that it will provide a nice
foundation for sort of understanding um
your thinking around this and um and
sort of how you've come to to really
embrace this um so i guess maybe you
could start first by you know talking
about the title of the book you know
it's part memoir
part
historical analysis part you know how to
guide on
being inclusive and
creating a place of belonging
how did you come up with the title why
did you choose this for the title of
your book so the title is go back to
where you came from and other helpful
recommendations on how to become
american very deliberate tongue and
tongue-in-cheek uh both ugly and funny
right because i believe that's the lived
experience of life but that's the living
experience of many americans who are
still trying to love a country that
doesn't love us back and so how do you
respond to that pain and some people cry
and you can as you can tell i laugh and
so this book is also an elegy
for the rest of us who are still
striving to be co-protagonist of this
american narrative and the book tries to
expand and stretch this country
to accommodate all of us to become the
multiracial democracy it has to become
or else i believe it'll all fail and
it's done with a lot of humor and hope
and throughout the journey you read the
book
you know we i talked about new zealand's
cancer but there's lots of interesting
things that happen to me
yeah my life is like a telenovela like a
mexican soap opera for better and for
worse and so i hope that when we get to
you know when you get to the the end
part where i talk about invest in hoba
tire camel first the hope that i give
the audience for the future
i don't want it to make it a hallmarky
fake saccharine hollywood ending i want
you to really like i want i want it to
be earned and you know and in order to
and the way to earn it is to confront
the horrors confront the challenges name
it own it talk about the pain where the
mileage and the scars but despite all
that you still persist right and and
because i agree i mean like what i said
in the speech is with the five minute
talk that i just gave you i believe in
it i've been on all the sides in moments
of deep despair i've been there
of darkness of pain and and i realize if
you tap out it's over if you tap out
it's done and and what i've
seen and we'll probably talk about it
because you read the book
in those moments in my life
where you feel like it's over it's done
i'm at the edge of the cliff and i'm
about to fall
there's been a plot twist
like the the page turns and with it
comes like a better story and so
in the book i mentioned there was a time
where i was completely broke
uh homeless my parents were in jail i
was taking care of my grandparents and
i'm like there's no way i i couldn't
even imagine my future i couldn't
imagine
living to the age of 40. i thought i
would be dead by 35 i'm being honest
with anyone who's listening
my timeline you know i imagine a lot i
said like doctor strange it ended at 35.
i just couldn't imagine and i just knew
that i would die i would be it'd be over
and i almost did die but here i'm
sitting
in my home married to a woman who's way
better than me like i'm married way up
like hotter than me smarter than me like
it's ridiculous it's not even cool and
then i got three kids and then nuseba
who was supposed to die that's what they
told me she wouldn't make it
they said every complication against
this girl
is is happening
you can just hear her tripping right now
i'm sure you guys can hear it tripping
that's nuseba so
so you never know you never know
you have a question that came in from
darcy where darcy asks the idea of
investing in hope is a great one but how
can we make it tangible you mentioned
visualization or avoiding complaining
but how else can we actually bring this
to life
it's a very good question uh and and and
you know that's where i say tire camel
first
uh you have to exhaust yourself of every
possibility within your control uh you
know and after that you have to let go
i'll give you an example it's i
mentioned in the book
there was a moment
my parents were in jail i'm 21 years old
i have to leave school i'm taking care
of my grandparents my grandmothers who
used to live with me i'm an only child
i could take care of the family business
i have to have to pay the lord it's post
9 11 my community turns vicious and
cruel bad news travels fast ladies and
gentlemen bad news travels fast i'm
surgical with my budget i have an excel
sheet i got to pay all the bills
according to my excel sheet
after i withdrew the 20
from wells fargo on the corner of warm
springs and mission i was supposed to
have 71 dollars left i go to the atm of
wells fargo
i take out the 20 bucks i get the
receipt i look at the bottom instead of
71 dollars it was 00.03
i 20 dollars zero zero point zero three
had to pay the bills pay the lawyer take
care of my family and i swear to you at
that time
i mean honestly i said i have done
everything in my power i am exhausted
what can i do with three cents i didn't
even get angry i didn't get upset i
remember this vividly was a beautiful
barrier day anyone who lives in the
berry you know 4 p.m a little bit of a
windy breeze the sun was still there was
just like idyllic and i remember i
started laughing look at the receipt and
a couple people behind me were trying to
figure out like what's wrong with this
guy because i was just i don't know what
else to do i just chuckled i got three
cents i had three cents left so this is
what i did
i took the twenty dollars went across
the street and decided to splurge i went
to subway and had a subway super-sized
meal footlong tuna sandwich with all the
workings and avocado and then i decided
to have two chocolate chip cookies then
i went next door and had a what is the
venti what's the largest one starbucks
one the i think thank you
caramel crap with extra caramel drizzle
right and i had now twenty dollars
became ten dollars i went home and i
told my grandparents and my grandmother
i said i've done everything i possibly
could
there's nothing else i can do we have
ten bucks left i'm sorry i had some
dolchamul at night uh watch a netflix
movie and i remember i said this in the
book i let go
there's nothing else i could do i
completely let go i said allah what you
know whatever happens tomorrow happens
tomorrow and shall i leave it up to you
i've done everything within my powers
like everything i could possibly think
of i've done this is it like you want to
save me sami you don't want to see me
whatever i enjoyed my subway meal and i
remember this is something really
interesting i had the best night's sleep
that night that i have ever had in my
life i remember that sleep to this day i
have prayed for that sleep i felt like i
was a baby
in my mother's womb i tried to wonder
why
it's because i knew that i did
everything within my powers i exhausted
myself and then i let it go and then
what happened somehow i got a loan and
2500 bucks came
and the journey the story continued and
so when you're saying about doing
something tangible that's not just me
saying that like you have to have some
feeling of control and autonomy in what
is a world where you feel adrift and the
ground is shifting beneath your feet
those small chores that you take for
granted
they'll give you order some discipline
i'm making that chai i'm painting this
i'm feeding my children i took out the
trash i did some work today i can
control this i did this with my hands
i'm still alive right and then you you
plot and you do the best you can and
then you let go and i think those daily
chores that daily routine
that you establish gives you a sense of
rhythm that the very least says the
world can take everything but it won't
take this
it won't take my delicious cup of chai
that i made with my own hands it won't
take this little
piece of plant you know this little
plant i potted a pla you know plotted
outside it won't take my love for my
kids it won't take that from me not
today death
not today
so i hope for whoever asked that
question i hope that was helpful
[Music]